قال المتحدث باسم الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل سامي الطاهري خلال مشاركته في تجمع
عماليا بمحافظه باجه قال انها تونس في خطر
وان الاتحاد لن يقبل بالاستبداد
وسيواجهه لانه يؤذن بالخراب على حد قوله
واعتبر طاهري ان الحكومه الحاليه تسير على
نفس خطى الحكومات السابقه في برنامج
التفكير والتجويع عبر رفع الدعم عن المواد
الاساسيه وابرام الاتفاقات السريه مع
صندوق النقد الدولي
في خطر وانا الاتحاد في خطر وانا تلزق خطر
ابنائها جزيلا ما تزيل صغار وكبار
وحده
كما كنا فيه 17 ديسمبر
وفي هذا الوقت يد واحده ولم يقبل
بالاستبداد وسن
وسنحاسبه
هذا هو نظم الاتحاد التونسي للشغل صباح
السبت تحركات احتجاجيه في محافظه الماديه
ضمن سلسله تحركات اقرتها الهيئه الاداريه
للمنظمه النقابيه للتنديد بترد الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وندد المتظاهرون
بما سموه استهداف السلطه للحريات النقابيه
والحريات بشكل عام
ولايه قفصه شهدت بدورها مظاهره نقابيه مدد
المشاركون فيها بمواصفوه ترد الحريات
النقابيه وتدهور القدره الشرائيه
للمواطنين
والمصادق عليها وشهدت تونس في الاربع
والعشرين ساعه الاخيره تسارعا في وتيره
التوقيفات والاعتقالات حيث اكدت هيئه
الدفاع عن المعتقلين فيما يعرف بقضيه
التامر على امن الدوله اصدار قرار جديد
بالسجن في حق القياديين بجبهه الخلاص
الوطني المعارضه في تونس رضا بلحاج وشيماء
عيسى وغازي الشواشي وكان قاضي التحقيق في
قضايا مكافحه الارهاب قد اصدر في وقت سابق
من فجر اليوم قرارات بالسجن في حق كل من
الناشطين السياسيين وهي خيام التركي وعبد
الحميد الجلاصي ورجل الاعمال كمال الصيف
والقيادي بجبهه الخلاص جوهر بن مبارك
والامين العام للحزب الجمهوريه عصام
الشابي
هذا وقال المحامي كريم المرزوقي عضو هيئه
الدفاع في القضيه التي تسميها السلطات
التامر على امن الدوله قال الجزيره ان
هيئه الدفاع قررت مقاطعه الترافع في
القضيه لانتقاء ابسط شروط المحاكمه
العادله
من جهته
قرار المقاطعه بعد
الترافع في ملفين اثنين وتبين لنا ان توجه
قاضي التحقيق في هذا الملف يتجه نحو اصدار
بطاقات ايداع في جميع الموقوفين بغض النظر
عن مضامين هذا الملف ولا يتم الترجيح بين
قراءه
الادانه فعلنا لان هذا الملف ملف التامر
الذي يستغل رئيس الجمهوريه
للتسويق ل اييي
للتسويق لما يقوم به اليوم من فشل على
المستوى الاقتصادي والاجتماعي
نحن في هيئه الدفاع نعتقد ان هذا الملف هو
محاكمه للراي محاكمه للمعارضه بالاساس
المعارضه التي لا يفوت رئيس الجمهوريه
الفرصه لاتهامها بالخيانه لاتهامها
بالعامله
ما قله كريم المرزوقي بالاحرى قال هيئه
الدفاع قررت مقاطعه الترافع في القضيه
الانتفاء ابسط شروط المحاكمه العادله من
جهتي دانا رئيس حركه النهضه التونسيه راشد
الغنوشي ما سماه الاعتقالات العشوائيه
للمناضلين الشرفاء
واخرهم رضا بلحاج وغازي الشواشي وطلب
باطلاق سراح جميع الموقوفين وقال الغنوشي
في بياننا الاعتقالات والتنكيله بالمعارضه
لن يحل مشاكل المواطنين ويسير بالبلاد نحو
عوده الديكتاتوريه ودوله التعذيب
في المقابل شدد رئيسه التونسي قيس سعيد
على ضروره فتح كل الملفات وخاصه تلك
المتعلقه بالفساد ومحاسبه كل من اجرم في
حق الشعب التونسي واتهم سعيد في اجتماع
بواسير الصحه علي مرابط اتهم اطرافا لم
يسميها بافتعال العقبات امام تنفيذ جمله
من المشاريع التي تاخر انجازها